let me tell you guys so i get this this
backpack here that's sent to me that you
know fedex box comes in jen's like babe
there's a gift waiting for you i open up
the fedex box i don't know what this is
i'm like okay why is
at first i'm worried because it's dirty
it's old i'm like who would send me a
gift like this you know so my kids are
sitting i started reading this letter
and i'm reading this letter by a man
named scott rodriguez i talk about this
at the beginning of the podcast first
generation american cuban he's 35 years
old at a san fernando valley santa clara
valley which very familiar with that
area county country valencia he talks
about his parents who started a business
with one truck in 1986 and they build it
in 2004 to 25 million dollar a year
business they sell it and they retire
and he's going to school while he's in
high school and you know he's got this
one teacher that he's working with mr
whitmire i believe is the name yeah carl
wittmeyer freshman year at heart high
school in new hall california in 2000
and carl came out of retirement to be a
teacher's aide in my studies skills
class okay so he's always there but he
never talks about military stories
because he used to be in the military he
used to be in the navy right for 16
years right and so he says he was a
gunner he's this and they say every time
i would go up to him to ask him stories
at 13 years old he was i was just a 13
year old boy he said he would never tell
me any of these stories anyways fast
forward
to the point where he's no longer coming
to school because he's got lung cancer
and he's asking everybody where is mr
whitmire i got emotional reading this i
had generated because it was an
emotional story anyways finally he finds
out that mr whitmer is in a hospital on
his deathbed
he says i come back to school january 6
2002 which is 20 years ago and mr
whitmer wasn't there in class
my teacher told me he was in a hospital
i jumped on the computer and started
typing a letter to mr wittmeyer i wrote
him to tell him that he what he meant to
me and how he touched my life i gave the
letter to my teacher since she said she
was heading to the hospital to see him i
looked at my teacher and said i don't
care what you do and how you do it but
make sure he gets this letter mr whitmer
passed 10 days later on january 16 2002
i walked into class and my teacher took
me to the hallway to tell me the bad
news she also had a box and a cart in
her hand she handed me this box and card
and mr whitmer wanted me to give you
this mr whitmer left me his world war ii
backpack wow
i cried and cried
was the first time i had lost someone i
loved this backpack represents freedom
patrick represents sacrifice love i want
you to have this gift from me and from
mr whitmire i know i don't know you
patrick but i'm so damn proud of you and
thankful for this it's freaking
emotional right wow let me tell you guys
this is the value of a person making a
positive impact in a 13 year old kid
that is now 35 years old american
cuban
first generation his parents set an
example this you know what this
represents to me values and principles
that's right this is values and
principles this is what we all want when
we were kids this is what a 16 year old
kid that maybe doesn't have it in his
[ __ ] he just wants somebody to say
listen lead
this is tough make the tougher choice
don't make the easier choice we are
living in a generation that these types
of mr no one's going to know mr
whitmeier
he's not going to be a guy that's going
to be known story's going to be written
about this guy but he made an impact in
a 13 year kid's life gives him this 20
years later
scott rodriguez gives it to me so
i know this whole thing kind of i don't
know how this happened but we're going
there you make the comment about
redemption and then we see the gallup
article that we saw yesterday on drudge
that we're talking about that goes to
scott rodriguez
scott i don't know if you're watching
this or not if you are i appreciate you
for this give your gift you're an
absolute stud uh uh more power to you
for the parents that raised you and as
well as you being able to give love to a
teacher like him and in sharing this
sentiment with me this is gonna be in
our podcast set i thank you for this
kind gift anyways we need more stories
like this amazing you have a mr
whitmeier story you have a mr whitmeier
story you have a mr whitmeier story we
all have a mr whitmeier story right so
if you're watching this you know maybe
maybe let's give a little bit credit and
stories to people like that in our lives
you got an instagram profile with 800
followers make a video and share the
story of your mr whitmeier okay i
remember years ago
i was at glendale high school 1.8 gpa 14
years old health and guidance teacher
this lady named sinclair was tough on me
challenged me i would always sit in the
back i never sat in the front i'm not a
front-sitting type of guy i sit in the
back because that's still you know you
can get away with a lot of stuff
she's like hey patrick you're sitting
right here she sits me right in front of
her which i'm like this is the worst
real estate i don't want to sit here
because
front accountability is low in the back
so next thing you know
i'm listening by the way she's 4 11 on a
good day okay
and long story short she's a major in
the army
because of her i later on joined the
army
i went back at 28 years old and i
surprised her i know at 33 years old 34
years old there's the videos online i
surprised her we took her a bunch of
gifts i talked to the principal she had
no clue i was doing this in front of all
her students i said how she changed my
life
and do you know miss sinclair and i for
the last 12 years we've been pen pals
she writes me letters when she dates a
guy she says i want you to meet this guy
i go have lunch with the guy and i said
so what do you think she calls me
afterwards we've done this multiple
times this woman changed my life she's a
regular human being that
made an impact on a 14 year old kid's
life that are 43 years old 30 years
later we remember that we need to tell
those stories
those day-to-day people that made a
positive impact we can't forget them we
got to recognize those folks as well
because if we don't the market's not
going to do it so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here